[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
88 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm good.
I had a nice relaxing weekend,
so it's super good to be back.
How are you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Doing great.
I also had a great, great great
weekend of machine learning
and sun, so yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice.
I did nothing technical.
I was at the beach.
It was fantastic.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I studied a
little bit, but it was fun.
I loved it.
And today we're going to have
a really cool conversation
about a topic that we
all love, Kubernetes--
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
--and specifically
about Kubernetes
1.7 with someone
that we had been wanting to
have in the podcast for quite
a while, Tim Hockin.
And he's--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, you
want to say his title.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: He's a
principal software engineer,
I think.
MARK MANDEL: Principal,
I think so, yes.
See
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Principal
software engineer in Google,
and he's one of the people that
really started the Kubernetes
project.
So he knows a lot
about it, of course.
MARK MANDEL: Super happy
to have him on the podcast.
Then we're going to
have a related Question
of the Week at the
end of the episode,
talking about what are
best practices for how
I should use pods, containers?
Like, how should I
structure these things?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, you
can put all of your things
in a container.
It does not mean you should.
MARK MANDEL: Really?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So, yeah, we'll
talk about that at the end.
But before that, we have
our Cool Things of the Week,
as usual.
And the first one
is something that I
have used before, especially
for demos, and it is super cool.
I'm pretty sure most of you
know about Cloud Shell, which
is the little shell that
you can get directly
from the Google Cloud console
for which you don't even
need to pay.
It's like that little shell
that it's part of your project,
so you have all
the authentication
and all the tooling.
You have GCloud and kubectl--
"cube cuddle"-- and all--
MARK MANDEL: kubectl.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --all of
those tools already installed
by default, which
is really cool.
Now it also comes
with an editor.
So if you don't want to
edit your files with Vim,
I don't know what you're
doing [INAUDIBLE],, but--
MARK MANDEL: Or [INAUDIBLE].
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
--or [INAUDIBLE]..
[LAUGHTER]
But you rather edit them
like a normal person,
like with a mouse and
moving around you can now,
which is really cool.
It's a very simple thing.
You just need to go and click
on Edit Files on the left side
of the Cloud Shell.
There's a place that will
show you all of the files
that you have.
You can edit them there.
And then you can access
those files directly
from Cloud Shell.
So for instance, let's
say you're using kubectl,
you can edit your .YAML directly
on that editor and then go like
kubectl create dash F,
whatever, which is very nice.
MARK MANDEL: You
mean cube control.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Whatever.
MARK MANDEL: That's fine.
But no, it is actually
a super cool project.
It's based on the open
source Eclipse Orion project.
It comes with
keyboard shortcuts,
syntax highlighting,
code completion,
find and replace for basically
a lot of supported languages
and configuration files.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And I
guess that the new thing is
that this is actually now a GA.
It used to be beta
for quite a while.
And now it is a GA,
which is really cool.
I have been using it.
And I definitely
recommend trying it
if you've never used it before.
The second one is about
App Engine and video games.
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHS]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
It is about how App Engine
helped power "Super Mario Run."
"Super Mario Run" is a
really cool video game
that is available on
both iOS and Android.
And it was kind of a big
deal, and you had, like,
huge scaling challenges
because it's like on Nintendo.
MARK MANDEL: Nintendo.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah
MARK MANDEL: Mario.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Like
"Pokemon Go," whatever,
like whenever you make a
really big game like this,
it's going to go
really, really viral.
So they explained
how they did it
to have zero problems
during the launch, which
is pretty amazing.
They explain all
the architecture
on how basically
everything is App Engine.
But they explain also how they
did the push notifications
for the all the phones, how
they make it so it runs faster.
So there's a lot
of Memcache stuff.
And then all the analytics
part of the things,
so it's like you'll see
Cloud Pub/Sub and Dataflow
and BigQuery.
And then [INAUDIBLE]
is a little bit
sprinkled on top, of course.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's super cool.
They simultaneously launched in
150 countries at the same time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: As you do.
MARK MANDEL: They
didn't even do-- like,
so it's quite regular
for game companies
to do a staggered
rollout across nations.
Pretty crazy how they did that.
One of the companies
behind it, D-E-N-A, Dena,
was able to complete a test
with three million accesses per
second when looking at
using Cloud Data Store
for their persistence layer.
It's pretty awesome
seeing the amount of scale
they were able to achieve.
I would say a pretty
successful launch.
I was pretty impressed with how
seamless it all seemed to go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And the cool thing is I
think it was like last week
or two weeks ago
that we used one
of the Cool Things of the
Week, that little video that
explains a little bit
how "Mario Run" was done.
Well, that video is
part of the blog post.
But that doesn't give
any detail compared
to how detailed the rest
of the blog post is.
So definitely go read
it, even if it's just
to see the Super Mario
running and jumping around.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
And so finally, last
Cool Thing of the Week
is a series of
seven hands-on labs
for scientific data processing
on Google Cloud Platform going
through plotting recent
earthquake activity to building
image processing with Apache
Spark to machine learning
and a variety of
other ones as well.
There's a variety of
technologies, too.
So it's not just TensorFlow.
It's a bunch of stuff.
And the nice thing is, is you
can either do this as just
like a step by step.
So if you have your
own GCP project,
you want to do it that way.
So it's available basically with
the [INAUDIBLE] documentation.
But you can also do
it through Quiklabs
as well, which means if you just
want to have Quiklabs fire up
a quick GCP project for you
temporarily without you having
to do a lot of the work,
it's able to do that as well,
which is super nice.
Yeah, there's a whole bunch
of really interesting stuff
from TensorFlow to
just using BigQuery.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
this is really cool.
I feel like after
spending the week
and learning machine
learning, this
may be a good continuation.
I really like that
one of the projects
is to predict the
correlation, not causation,
even though, in
this case, I'd say
that it's highly correlated,
of the mean daily temperature
versus how many people
call 311 complaining
about their hot
water not working.
[LAUGHTER]
Surprisingly, people complain
more about the hot water
not working when
it's really cold.
MARK MANDEL: Huh, funny that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, shocking.
MARK MANDEL: Who knew?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Definitely check it out.
There's a lot of
really cool projects.
There's actually
a bunch of them.
TIM HOCKIN: Yeah,
seven, it's pretty cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
so why don't we
go have a chat with
our new friend Tim
and talk all about
Kubernetes 1.7?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds good.
Let's do that.
So it is a huge honor today
to be joined by Tim Hockin.
Tim Hockin is a principal
software engineer
here at Google and also one
of the first engineers working
in the Kubernetes project,
which is pretty awesome.
So Tim, welcome to the podcast.
How are you doing?
TIM HOCKIN: I'm well, thank you.
I'm glad to be here today.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank
you for joining us.
We're going to be talking
today mostly about Kubernetes
and the latest version, 1.7.
But before we get started
into all the details
and new features and
stuff, why don't you
tell us a little
bit about yourself
and what you do here at Google.
TIM HOCKIN: Sure.
Well, I've been at
Google a very long time.
But most recently
I've been working
on the Kubernetes and Google
Container Engine project.
I was one of the first
engineers on the project, one
of the original
four, I like to say.
I work on things like networking
storage, API, node, federation,
plug-ins, cloud provider,
those sorts of things, mostly
the lower level
parts of the system,
the infrastructure for the
infrastructure, if you will.
I'm also working on things
like governance and steering
committee, setting overall
direction for the project,
both inside Google
with Container Engine
and with Kubernetes
proper, though I reserve
the right to hold opinions on
things that I don't necessarily
work on, which I think every
contributor to the project
is probably run into.
I also do a lot of
outreach and evangelism.
I go and talk to a lot
of customers and users
and would-be users
and conferences
and those sorts of things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I've seen
you on stage a couple of times.
I've got to say, those talks
are really, really good.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So you mentioned
that you've been at Google
for a very long time.
And now I'm curious--
for how long?
TIM HOCKIN: I joined in 2004,
so that puts me at 13 years.
MARK MANDEL: Wow.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK,
that is a very long time.
MARK MANDEL: That's
a long time, nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: That's super cool.
So we've had several
episodes on Kubernetes.
But I always love
asking this question
because we get
different perspectives
on the project, which I
think are really interesting.
So if you had to give sort
of like a two or three
minute description
of what Kubernetes
is if people haven't
come to it before,
how would you
describe Kubernetes?
TIM HOCKIN: Kubernetes
is, in a sentence,
it's a container
management system.
I think the important
part here is
that it's a cluster management,
and it brings these new ideas--
or not new, but a
different idea--
of how people should
manage their workloads.
It takes the lessons
that we've learned
by doing this for a long time
at Google and brings it out
and shows people
sort of how we work,
why we think it's a
successful way to work,
and brings forward
these primitives.
So it's somewhat
opinionated, in that it's
got some basic ideas of how
we think you should do things.
But it's not very
opinionated, in that
there's a lot of
flexibility, and you
can do things in many,
many ways within the bounds
of Kubernetes.
And you can evolve your
operations over time.
We bring this idea
that you should
manage your workloads
in aggregate instead of
in singletons.
You should not be
thinking about which
particular instance of your
application is doing what.
You should be thinking
about the number of replicas
you need and the scale
out, and the resources
should be allocated and managed
by the system automatically.
These are not problems
that people, humans,
are good at thinking about.
We should let the machines
deal with those problems.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
You mentioned
previously, as well,
that you do some governance
and some aspects of sort
of the community.
It seems like the
community is a huge deal,
like that the fact
that it exists
and how large it
is for Kubernetes.
Can you talk a
little bit about it?
Is it still growing?
Like, what's happening with
the community right now?
TIM HOCKIN: The community is
the single most important facet
of the Kubernetes project.
It is the reason that
Kubernetes is as successful
as it has been.
The community is enormous.
It's overwhelming, honestly.
The last time I looked we
had over 2,500 contributors
across all of our
different repos,
coming from literally
hundreds of companies.
We're pulling in somewhere
between 40 and 50 commits a day
to the code base.
We're pushing our 50,000
commit number soon.
And it's incredible that we
have this many people working
on this little idea that we had.
And the community has just
been such an integral part
of the process.
It has simultaneously
forced us to be
more open with how we do
things, which has been
really good for the project.
But it's also forced
us to let go of parts
that we wanted to work on
or that historically we've
sort of owned.
And we've let
community own things.
And it's been, I'd say,
overall wildly successful
and incredibly difficult.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So I'm wondering--
we mentioned community.
How big is the community?
Like how many contributors?
Could you tell everybody
how many people are actually
working on Kubernetes,
let alone using it,
but actually actively
developing it?
TIM HOCKIN: Sure.
I mean the number of
total unique contributors
is over 2,500.
That doesn't mean that 2,500
people are contributing
on a regular basis, right?
A lot of those are one-time
contributions or people
who contributed and then went
away to do something else.
I don't have the number
off the top of my head.
But I'd say it's
probably on the order
of several hundred 30-day
unique contributors from dozens
and dozens of companies.
I mean, obviously, we have big
contributing companies Red Hat,
and we have many, many smaller
contributing companies.
And we have a lot of
people who are just
starting to contribute.
Our Slack is filled
with thousands of people
asking and answering questions
from each other all day long.
Our mailing list is
incredibly useful.
And people are there answering
questions for each other.
We have thousands
of GitHub forks.
We have hundreds of
meet-ups around the world.
By most metrics, we're the
busiest project on GitHub.
So, yeah, those are some
basic numbers for you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
I like to think myself as
one of the contributors
because I fixed one typo
in the documentation once.
TIM HOCKIN: There you go.
[LAUGHTER]
You are one of those 2,500.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That counts.
Yep.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: I
better do something.
I better get stuck in there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
I got a cool T-shirt that
said contributor with a K.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So there you go.
MARK MANDEL: There you go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So let's
get started a little bit
with more technical stuff.
Kubernetes 1.7 has
a lot of new things.
I was looking at
the release notes,
and it's kind of amazing
and almost, like, scary
how many new things are coming.
But why don't you
tell us a little bit
about what are the main topics
and your favorite features
maybe.
TIM HOCKIN: Sure.
I mean, the release notes
are overwhelming, right?
It's like 30 pages
of release notes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
TIM HOCKIN: You have
to remember Kubernetes
is an enormous
surface area, right?
Everything from network
infrastructure to the API
to the machinery that drives the
APIs to all the workloads, all
of these things are being driven
by different teams, right?
We have over 100 people
at Google working on it,
and those people are
doing full-time work.
So the rate of
change is just huge.
It's not really
that surprising when
you look at the surface
area of it, right?
It's when you sit down to
try to read the release notes
and ingest the whole thing at
once that it becomes scary.
What are my favorite parts?
I mean, obviously,
I'm a little biased
towards the parts
that I'm closest to.
And I'm close to them because
I'm interested in them.
But some of the
things that I thought
were really cool
in 1.7 release are
things like network
policy, which
went GA, which lets you sort
of describe micro-segmentation
on your network.
We have this ability to
preserve client IPs across load
balancers now,
which is something
that people asked
for a long time.
We have this new
aggregated PI system,
which I think is just
phenomenally cool.
We've been talking about
it for literally two years
and working out
how to get it done.
And now that it works, it's
actually pretty awesome.
We have lots of new,
sort of, small features
that make the overall
distributedness of the system
better, things
like initializers,
which lets you do
out-of-process asynchronous
initialization of objects.
We have audit logging
finally, and it's just
a super cool feature for you to
be able to see who changed what
and when about my cluster.
We have the beginnings of
a much more secure system.
We have encryption at rest.
We have-- we're working
on moving all the cloud
providers out of our tree.
I like to say I'm kicking
Google out of Kubernetes.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: Hmm.
TIM HOCKIN: And it's
a really big deal
because it's going to
help the code base scale,
and it's going to allow
us to expand more broadly.
We've got a new
metrics API, which
means we can finally start to
do things like auto-scaling
based on custom metrics.
The internal runtime
interface, the CRI,
we removed all of the
legacy Docker code.
It's now only CRI
Docker, which is
a phenomenal internal cleanup.
We have local storage
that's been introduced,
which is something that
people have been asking for,
for a long time.
I mean, I could go on and on.
But these are some of
the things that jump out
to me about this release.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so there's
really nothing going on at all.
Like, it's just been quiet.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Yeah, Kubernetes
is really not --
I don't know.
200 engineers, they're
not doing much.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it's--
I don't know.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: No.
So instead of trying
to list all of them,
because, as you mentioned,
there's so many of them,
I think that we have a
list of like the ones
that we consider
to be the coolest.
So why don't you go first
with some of your favorites.
And we asked Tim to--
MARK MANDEL: That sounds good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --explain a
little bit why it's important.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
so Tim actually
brought up one of my favorites.
So it feels like
Kubernetes in the beginning
was kind of like, we
think you were going
to solve sort of the 80%
rule, like this is what we
think 80% of the people need.
And then as we've headed
down the road map,
things have got more--
we still do that.
But we're now going to allow
you to have hooks and things you
can do to really
customize Kubernetes
to be exactly what you need for
exactly what your workload is.
So that brings me to things like
the API aggregation-type stuff
that you alluded to earlier.
Can you sort of explain what
that is and how that works?
I think this is a really,
really cool thing.
TIM HOCKIN: Sure.
So one of the things I think
that makes Kubernetes really
powerful is the consistent API.
We have one API server
that has a set of semantics
for how you interact with it.
And all of our APIs conform
to that same API server.
And they're all discoverable
in the same way,
and they're all sort of
interoperable in the same way.
And what that means is you
can have one set of tooling
and one sort of client
concept that works across all
of those different APIs.
And like you said, it's sort of
the 80% rule, although I don't
think we're quite at
80% yet, but the things
that we know how to
handle, sort of, natively
built into Kubernetes.
And then there's this
wide landscape of ideas
that people have
of things either
that they want to
add to Kubernetes
but they need to prove
themselves first,
or things that they don't
want to add to Kubernetes,
but they want to
use with Kubernetes
in the same way as Kubernetes
but probably will never
be part of the core system.
And we've heard that
people who want to do this,
and what we've given them
is this aggregated API.
And so what it means
is you can essentially
run your own program in your
cluster or out of your cluster.
It doesn't really matter.
The program will register
with the API server
as a specific sub API.
And then you can use
all the existing tooling
that you've got--
Cube Control and all
of the other pieces.
And they just work
with the new API,
as if that type that
you just registered
was part of the built-in API.
When you post an HTTP
request to our API server,
it gets passed through
onto your own API server,
where you have a chance to
validate it, do admission
control, do sanity
checking of the input,
reject the request
if you need to.
And if you accept it, then
it becomes a stored object
in the same way that anything
else in the Kubernetes system
works.
And it's essentially
transparent to the client.
And because something
like kubectl
does automatic probing
of the API server,
you can, in fact,
just start using it
without any changes
needed in your client.
MARK MANDEL: So has this got a
relationship to custom resource
definitions?
Is that right?
TIM HOCKIN: Yeah, so
we started talking
about this aggregated API
idea a couple of years ago.
And when we scoped it out,
it was sort of big and hairy
and complicated.
And so the predecessor to
custom resource definitions,
which is third-party
resources, was
sort of the poor man's
version of aggregated API.
It was a simple way
to do essentially
the CRUD operations--
Create, Read,
Update, and Destroy.
But it didn't have the
opportunity for you
to hook in and do synchronous
validation, right?
You could never do a
sort of schematic check
on it to make sure that, say,
you have an integer field
and it has to be
greater than 10.
There was no way for us
to validate that, right?
You had to do that
sort of after the fact.
And that was great,
and it lets people
do a lot of really
neat prototyping stuff
really, really cheaply.
But I think the
aggregated API gives you
a much more robust way to take
those ideas into production.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So would
you say that custom resource
definitions is kind
of like a good way
to start if you want
to enhance the API,
but if you want to
get more serious you
should go with API aggregation?
Or should you just use API
aggregation rather than
custom resource definitions?
TIM HOCKIN: I think
you said it right.
I think custom
resource definition
is the way you start.
It's the lowest barrier to
entry to making extensions
to the Kubernetes API.
In fact, we request
anybody who's
trying to propose a
new Kubernetes API,
that you start with
something like a CRD
and you demonstrate the value
of what you're working on.
You work out the API, and
you implement your back ends
against it, and you sort of
get everything sorted out.
And then when that
looks pretty good,
then we can talk about
inclusion as a built-in API,
or we can talk about
moving it to something
like an aggregated API.
Or you can leave that as a
CRD, if that's sufficient
for you and it satisfies
what you need to do.
CRD is the lowest
barrier to entry.
Aggregated API is a
significantly higher barrier
to entry, but not nearly as high
as adding something built in.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Let's move to the next topic.
I'm curious about this
thing because I've always
heard about it as
being something
that people consider
an anti-pattern, which
is PetSets, or StatefulSets.
You are adding more things to
StatefulSets in this release.
Could you tell us a
little bit about what
is, first, StatefulSets
and then when to use them?
TIM HOCKIN: Sure.
Now, PetSet is sort
of a dirty word, so--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I know.
[LAUGHTER]
TIM HOCKIN: So the idea stems
from this pets-cattle analogy
that has sort of made
its way around the space.
And Kubernetes really embraces
the idea of cattle and scale
out and replicas.
And that's really good
for a large class of work,
where you can just add
more copies of your thing
and it will scale.
It doesn't really
satisfy the case of I
have a database, right?
I have something that's
really important,
and I have to
protect that state.
And this pattern sort
of is at the bottom
of every major
application, right?
It's the database.
It's your Mongo.
It's your My SQL.
So once we sort of decided
we were successful enough
at stateless applications,
the scale-out web-serving sort
of applications, people wanted
to run stateful applications.
They said, well, how
does Google do it?
And we said, well, you know,
the Google model within Borg
is a little different
than the Kubernetes model.
And we took a hard look at
what people were trying to do,
and we came up with
this idea of sort
of a different primitive that
has some of the same properties
as deployments or
replica sets but is
different in really
fundamental ways.
And that was what became
what was then called PetSet,
which evolved into StatefulSet.
And some of the
differences are things
like you're not going to
scale it out in general.
And if you do, it's not a
cavalier operation, right?
You can't just throw
another replica at it.
It's typically something
where maybe you have a quorum,
and so you have to have
an odd number of replicas.
Or you need to do sort of
an introduction step, where
you introduce a
new replica and it
meets all of the other
replicas, and then
you can add a second one.
So you can't add five
at a time, for example.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL:
TIM HOCKIN: And the identity of
these replicas sort of matters,
right?
Whether you're shard one
or shard two actually
is significant.
And maybe you have
state that you're
storing that is related to your
particular index in this array.
And so these are the
those sort of primitives
that are added, right?
Within a replica
set or a deployment,
replicas are all
assumed fungible.
You don't have an index.
You don't have an
ordinal number.
Nobody is the zeroth entry.
And within a PetSet,
or a StatefulSet,
you absolutely do, right?
You know exactly how
many replicas you have,
and you know which one you are.
And it is tied to
volumes, so you
can have a volume that goes with
each copy of your StatefulSet
application.
And there's rules about
how upgrades are done
across StatefulSet replicas.
And we've taken the assumption
that there must be state here,
so be super, super careful.
And we've traded
instead of being really
fast at doing
rolling updates, it's
much more careful,
much more safe,
which means things are going to
be necessarily slower and more
complicated.
So now that said,
what's changed in 1.7
is we've extended it to support
things like rolling updates,
right?
So previously,
StatefulSet didn't even
support rolling update.
If you wanted to update
your application,
you had to manually go through
and remove each replica
and let each replica
get replaced.
And so now we actually have
a rolling update ability,
where you can kick it, and
it will do that automatically
for you.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So Francesc and I have listed
both two of our favorite sort
of things in this list.
Tim, do you have a
particular favorite one
you want to go deeper onto?
TIM HOCKIN: I mean, I
love network policy.
I think it's a really cool API.
It's been beta for a
while, but it's finally GA.
Network policy lets
you sort of abstractly
describe the graph
of your application,
like which things are allowed
to talk to which other things.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
TIM HOCKIN: And
then you can enforce
at the network level,
anything that's not described
by this graph is disallowed.
And so I can say,
like my front ends
can talk to my middle tier.
And my middle tier can
talk to my database.
My front ends can never
And my front ends can
never talk to each other
because that would be weird.
And once I've drawn
that graph, then
if I have the right sort
of network installation--
and it's an abstract API, right?
So if you have the right network
config, then you turn it on,
and the network config
will start enforcing it.
And suddenly those packets
between the front end
and the database
just get dropped.
They go away into the ether,
and there's nothing that
if your front end got
compromised somehow,
it cannot attack the database.
MARK MANDEL: That's super cool.
I didn't know that.
So as an interesting
aside then, is that
somehow related to what's going
on in, say, the Istio project?
Or is this outside
of your purview?
TIM HOCKIN: No, this
is-- so network policy
is at the layer 3,
layer 4, IP plus port.
Istio is at layer 7, right?
It's really aware
of identity and it's
using that as it's rules.
They are very similar, and I
think they're complimentary.
The network policy can act
as a really nice backstop
behind Istio policies,
or layer 7 policies.
Istio's just a specific
implementation of that.
So I think they
work well together.
I think space is very
new, and we're still
trying to figure out exactly
what is going to happen there,
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So we already have been
talking for over 20 minutes.
[LAUGHTER]
So we're almost
running out of time.
But before we do
that, I actually
would like to talk a little
bit about the future.
So is there anything
on the roadmap
1.8 or later that
you'd like to mention
that you're excited about?
TIM HOCKIN: I don't want
to pick on any one thing
from like the 1.8 roadmap.
There's a bunch of features.
You can go look at
the features repo
and see what people
are working on for 1.8.
I like to think a
little bit further out
and see what the major
trends within the system are.
I think extensions and
modularity is a major trend.
You've seen a lot of
work happening here
with CRDs, with aggregated
APIs, with plug-in systems,
with things like Ingress, which
are sort of abstract APIs,
with cloud providers, with
now kube control plug-ins.
You can actually do
client-side plug-ins.
I think that the directions with
Istio are really interesting.
I think we don't really know
what we're doing there yet,
but I think that Istio
has demonstrated that this
is a really cool space.
I think things like Service
Broker are really exciting.
And I think that
that is going to be
a big part of how
people consume services
and Kubernetes in the future.
I'm looking forward to
better cloud support.
As more cloud support
Kubernetes more natively,
we're getting better
primitives out of these clouds.
I know the team
here at Google Cloud
is obviously working very hard
to make Google Cloud support
containers more directly.
I think we're going to see
really cool things with easier
and richer installation
and configuration
of clusters, more
consistent hybrid stories,
so you can run clusters
in multiple locations
and sort of use the same tools.
Right now it's open source,
so it's sort of the Wild West,
and everybody's doing
their own thing.
And I think we're
coming to a place
where we can start to
get some convergence.
I think the local storage idea
is just scratching the surface.
I think we're going to see a
lot better system de-bugability
introspection, a lot
less reasons to SSH
into your machines, and a
lot better automatic tooling.
These are the big trends
that I'm paying attention to.
Security, obviously
we're getting better at.
With the encryption
at rest, we'll
have more secrets and
off plug-ins and secret
plug-ins and
encryption providers
and automatic identity providers
and those sorts of things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
Well, I have to ask a question.
TIM HOCKIN: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cube C-T-L,
cube control, or cube cuddle?
TIM HOCKIN: In my real
life, I say cube cuddle.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
TIM HOCKIN: When I'm talking--
when I'm talking
publicly, I sometimes
say cube control because
apparently that's
what most people
expect it to be.
But I still think they're
wrong, and it's cube cuddle.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
I was curious, because you
actually used both during the--
MARK MANDEL: You did.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
--during the podcast.
TIM HOCKIN: So, yes,
I caught myself.
I try to say cube control
when I'm presenting something.
And I caught myself
saying cube cuddle once.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I think
cube cuddle is the way
to go anyway, So yeah.
MARK MANDEL: I have
a twitch in my eye.
[LAUGHTER]
It's probably going to go
away any minute now, I'm sure.
TIM HOCKIN: Well, I
mean, the alternative
that I proposed
on Twitter, which
didn't get a whole lot
of likes, was "kub ectl,"
which is obviously--
[LAUGHTER]
--which is in alignment
with ioctl, right?
[LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, true.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: "kub ectl," you
know, I could get behind that.
[LAUGHTER]
I could totally get behind that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We
need to make T-shirts.
MARK MANDEL: That's fantastic.
Cool.
Well, like we could talk to
you for ages and ages and ages.
But before we wrap up,
is there anything at all
that you want to
mention or plug?
Or is there a feature that
you just think's amazing
and we haven't managed to cover
it that you want to talk about
before we wrap up things here?
TIM HOCKIN: I mean, I
think I've talked about
all my favorite Pet features.
The thing I want to plug
most is the community.
I want people who are listening,
who maybe are using Kubernetes
ideas but aren't
really participating,
to come and participate.
The water's warm.
Come in and file bugs, right?
Try things out.
And every time
something doesn't work
the way you think it
should, every time you
have a little bit of
friction, file a bug.
This is how I
became the top fug--
the top fug biler--
the bug filer--
[LAUGHTER]
--too, is by trying
the system out
and trying to push the
boundaries of what the API can
do and finding weird
places where things didn't
work the way I expected them.
And surprise is
never a good thing,
so I want everybody
who's using the system
to file a bug every
time you get surprised.
And come in, and if you've
got some Pet thing that you
want to see change,
like the code is
daunting because
of the size of it,
but we'll help you find the
places where you need to tie in
and scratch your own itches.
This is open source.
It's been a wildly successful
open source project.
I think it's demonstrated the
real power of open source.
I just want more people
to participate and engage.
We need help on things like
contributor experience.
We need help on
things like tooling.
You don't have to be
a PhD systems engineer
to participate in
this community.
You can come in and help
us with our build systems,
with our shell scripts, with our
tools and test infrastructure,
and with our GitHub bots.
All of these things, I think,
are relatively low barrier
to entry.
Even docs, just
contributing to the docs
is massively important.
Number one complaint that
we hear about Kubernetes
over and over again is that
the docs could be better.
And they're getting better.
We need help.
Many hands make light work.
MARK MANDEL: That reminds me.
I've had a patch that
I've had to do that I've
been wanting to put in--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
You should do it.
MARK MANDEL: --for like four
weeks now that I should do.
[LAUGHTER]
TIM HOCKIN: This
time next year, I'd
like the contributors number
to be 5,000 instead of 2,500.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
challenging, but OK.
MARK MANDEL: OK, so hold on.
It is-- we're recording
on the 29th of July.
If we come back in a year's
time, we'll have Tim on.
We'll see if you're right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Deal.
MARK MANDEL: Deal.
Awesome, well, Tim, thank you so
much for spending time with us.
We really appreciate it.
This has been a great
conversation around Kubernetes.
And thank you so much for
helping start the project.
I mean, I love Kubernetes.
It's one of my favorite things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Thank you so much.
TIM HOCKIN: No, thank--
MARK MANDEL: Thank you
so much for joining us.
TIM HOCKIN: Thank you
guys for having me.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks again
to Tim for joining us
for today's interview.
As we've said a couple
of times, definitely
wanted to have him on the
podcast for a really, really,
really long time.
So glad we could manage to
find a great time for us
to sit down and have a chat.
Learned a whole bunch of
stuff about Kubernetes 1.7
I'm super excited
about this release.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, this
was one of those interviews
that I really didn't
want to finish.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So many questions,
and he's such a cool guy.
I wanted to keep talking to him.
But anyway, I guess
it's time to go
with our Question of the
Week, which fortunately
is about the same topic.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So it seems like a fairly common
question in a lot of ways.
And I've definitely
come across this
before, where it's
like, OK, I have pods.
I have containers.
How much stuff do I put
inside my containers?
How much stuff do I
put inside my pods?
Is there this
magical silver bullet
for like a rule that I can
just apply for just giving me
the best way to do this?
Francesc, tell me more.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
The answer is no.
There's no silver bullet.
[LAUGHTER]
Because that's the whole point
of a silver bullet, if they--
or maybe they exist.
I don't know.
MARK MANDEL: They
exist for werewolves.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
But, yeah, whatever.
Sure, OK.
[LAUGHTER]
Anyway, not really, but
there are some good practices
or a good way of
understanding what pods
versus containers
are that might help
you guiding the decision
between putting everything
in a pod or everything
in a container
or whatever you want to do.
And there's actually
a really good talk
by a very good
friend, Tim Hockin--
MARK MANDEL: Strangely that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --strangely.
We'll have a link
in the show notes.
And it's called "Kubernetes--
Understanding Pods
Versus Containers."
And he uses a very
cool metaphor,
which is imagine that
you're thirsty, right?
And if you're thirsty,
I could give you
just a bunch of particles,
like electrons and neutrons
and protons, and then
you do it, right?
And it's like,
sure, but no, right?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Like,
that's not very helpful.
That could be like,
well, do you have
all of these different
libraries and tools and things?
Then it just gives them to you.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
You want them to be
organized in some way
in order to be useful.
So, yeah, you're getting a
drink, fundamental particles.
That's not a good idea.
The second part
is like, well, I'm
just going to give you
like hydrogen and oxygen,
and just, like, you
figure it out, right?
And that might be like
containers, right?
You have a container,
which is hydrogen,
which hydrogen, by the way, is
one proton, one neutron, one
electron.
Oxygen is one proton, one
neutron, one electron.
So you have that,
and just, like, OK,
still not good enough, right?
So sometimes what a
container is, is not enough.
You want higher level
of organization,
and that's exactly when
you put them together,
and you're just like, oh,
what if I put together
the hydrogen and the oxygen
and put two hydrogens and one
oxygen. Now, all of
a sudden, there's
two containers of hydrogen,
one container of oxygen,
and you have water,
which is a pod.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So that's
the whole idea, right?
Like, hydrogen is a
useful thing by itself.
But it is when you put it
together with another hydrogen
and oxygen that you get all that
useful thing, which is water.
Imagine that you
want a sweet water.
Sweet water is it called?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
sweet water, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, whatever.
MARK MANDEL: Water with sugar.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sugary water.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You could
put it together the same,
in a single pod.
You could put the
sugar and the water.
But then the problem is that
the sweetness of the end product
is fixed, right?
You cannot augment the amount
of water or sugar without
augmenting the other one.
MARK MANDEL: And maybe
I find it too sweet.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So the whole idea is
that, well, if you have it
in different pods,
all of a sudden
your cluster can scale
up the amount of water
or scale down the
amount of sugar
independently from each other.
And that's the whole idea.
So you have containers, which
are like basic useful things--
hydrogen, oxygen.
Then you have pods,
which are useful things, which
are like water and sugar.
And since they're
separated, you can actually
scale them differently.
And I think that's a
beautiful metaphor.
MARK MANDEL: I think
that works really well.
So basically, I
want to think about
what are the things that
need to be held together,
but what are the things that
I want to keep separate.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: And making
sure those two rules
don't necessarily overlap in
ways that I don't mean them to.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: If we go
to an example like with
a three-layered tier whatever--
MARK MANDEL: So I
might have my database.
I don't want that to
scale up and down.
I want that to stay
relatively static.
So that's one that might--
a database process that
runs inside a container,
probably inside something
like a StatefulSet.
And I might run
just one of them.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Or you
might have like a distributed
one, where you have
like a cluster,
and you have like three of them.
But they're like three,
and they're pretty stable--
MARK MANDEL: They're stable.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --overall.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And then
you have the web servers.
And the web servers
maybe have more of those.
And maybe inside of every
single web server there's a pod.
And you have one thing
which is a micro-service
to do something.
And then you the other
one, which is log.
Logging without
the micro-service
doesn't make any sense, right?
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So you put
them together inside of a pod.
But if you have like customer
macro-service and content
micro-service, they
may be different,
because you maybe
you need more traffic
into customers than the other
one that is add content.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
that's a whole metaphor,
the water-sugar.
MARK MANDEL: And
by the same token,
you wouldn't want to mix your
web stuff with your database,
because that would be like--
we don't want to scale up
the database at the same time
as we'd scale up our web stuff,
and keep that all separate.
I like that.
That's a cool metaphor.
I like it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, it's
a very, very good metaphor,
so I thought it was a really
good way of explaining it.
I do not think there's a
recording for this talk.
But there's lots up there, so
we'll have a link in the show,
and so you can check them out.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
All right, Francesc,
before we wrap up
today, what are you up to?
Where are you going?
Is there a Just for Funk?
I'm sure there's
a Just for Funk.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
there was a Just for Funk
that I published last week,
and it's doing really well.
I think it's almost
like 4,000 views.
It's about testing and
testing web servers
and stuff like that, which
apparently people like.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: After that,
I will be releasing one
next week, which might
include some guest star,
such as this guy
called Mark Mandel,
if he'll ever record with me.
Who knows.
MARK MANDEL: Who knows.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Who knows.
But other than that,
I'm going to be
going to Spain to
enjoy some holidays,
and then I'll be
back in September.
I'm not sure where I'm
going to be in September.
I might go to Australia.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: That'd be good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, in Sydney.
MARK MANDEL: The irony,
the irony's impressive,
but that's good.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What about you?
MARK MANDEL: What am I up to?
So I'm not going anywhere
until the end of August,
where I will be
speaking at PAX Dev
and then attending PAX itself.
After that, in September--
September's crazy.
I'll be at Gamercon Las Vegas.
I'll be at Austin
Game Conference.
And I'll be attending
Strange Loop as well,
one of my favorite conference.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Oh, Strange Loop,
yeah, that's going to be fun.
MARK MANDEL: Yep,
super, super excited
about all of that stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Well,
it's almost time to finish,
but before we finish, there
is something that we have not
done in a very long time.
MARK MANDEL: Let's do it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, which is, so we
love talking to you people.
Send us your
Questions of the Week.
Send us your Cool Things.
Send us everything.
Send us even jokes.
We love jokes or
pictures of puppies.
In order to do so,
you have a bunch
of different ways of doing it.
One of them is Twitter.
MARK MANDEL: @GCPpodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
We're also on Google+.
MARK MANDEL: +GCPpodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We
also have a sub reddit.
MARK MANDEL: /r/gcppodcasst.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
We have a web page.
MARK MANDEL: gcpodcast.com.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We emails.
MARK MANDEL: At
hello@gcppodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Too many
ats there, but whatever.
[LAUGHTER]
And finally, we
are also on Slack.
MARK MANDEL: At the hash podcast
channel on the GCP community
Slack, you can find it
at bit.ly/gcp-slack.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That is
amazing that you remember that.
[LAUGHTER]
So anyway, thanks, Mark, so
much for taking the time today
to talk about Kubernetes
with Tim Hockin.
Thanks again to Tim Hockin
for letting us interview him.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, and thank
you everyone for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: See
you all next week.